[Musik]
[Applaus]
und 25
[Musik]
so viele spiele sich völlig gelohnt
später klavier lehrerin manuela keller
ist einer der koordinatoren von 100 und
ein pianist bei diesem event spielen 100
kinder gemeinsam mit lang lang auf der
bühne klavier eine art öffentlicher
meisterkurs den lang land stiftung seit
15 jahren auf der ganzen welt
veranstaltet
jetzt soll 100 und ein pianist auch in
zürich aufgeführt werden
[Musik]
sie bringen schauer - bürgermeister
bewusst und würden damit jetzt nötig
[Musik]
instrumentenflügen so sagen jetzt müsst
ihr instrument so verteilt
er hat wie er zwischen treten so insel
wo die richtige musik statt während dann
durch linie wo der 58 stimmen das sind
sehen sie mal unser team als instrument
wir stellen uns herausfordern mit ihr
auf der bühne liegen ganze los packt ich
nehme jetzt mal raus ich bin ziemlich
vor der rostocker deine so oft
behinderten zudem den grünen bringen und
logistik editoren haben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bild zeige dass man nicht ob oder das
auch tun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben das ganz lustig wir haben das
wort club lang langs 30 geburtstag das
hatten wir irgendwie im fernsehen
gesehen da hatte ich weiß ich weiß
überhaupt in berlin war oder wo auch
immer da gab es schon dieses projekt 101
pianisten und da wurden auch
militärmarsch und ungarischer tanz
aufgeführt dann dann dann hat uns das
damals eigentlich vor knapp fünf jahren
inspiriert das stück dann auch zusammen
einzuheben
[Musik]
wenn wir was machen dann muss man alles
geben und das gehört auf jeden fall
disziplin dazu wenn man was gutmachen
will
man braucht talent ist es einer aber
ohne freies ohne disziplin kann man auch
ziemlich nichts erreichen natürlich
braucht man auch ein bisschen glück dazu
aber disziplin also ich finde ich dann
schon sehr wichtig ja es war so ich
hatte zu ihm gesagt so diesen sommer
lernen wer schwimmen und da sagte er zu
mir lieber klavier spielen und ja dann
haben wir ein bisschen angefangen und
das schwimmen hat er trotzdem gelernt
natürlich aber er war sehr ehrgeizig
[Musik]
das hat natürlich alles vorne nicht
gestimmt am anfang hatte ich sogar
gedacht er sei total unmusikalisch ebene
kann ich ja das war desto besser es war
wirklich keine freunde dazu zu hören und
dann wird er sogar besser und besser
[Musik]
irgendwann hat es auch beethoven
variationen gespielt habe ich plötzlich
gemerkt dass musik gar nicht
hatte nicht mehr einfach die noten
abgespielt er hatte wirklich also von
sich aus eine interpretation reingelegt
in das stück ja was ich ihnen
beigebracht hatte
da muss man das natürlich da eine
professionelle hände geben
[Musik]
was hast du für deinen hintern der
stunde zum vorbereitet
[Musik]
das schloss ist habe ich mich nur
bescheidene zeichnet also doch können
sie die leute immer weiß dass ich das
hätte glaubt wieder down under nicht
könne ja schluss ihr euch als ziel vom
weg wo in sachen 90
also einfach allgemein
[Musik]
beispiel warum täter zu einem
unterzubringen sondern kommt im jahr
will davon ist der garten und der dunkle
locken also genau darum dass gott mehr
automatisch wenn du zweimal derzeit
wegen nimmt es genau
also wir sind also so bezog mal jene
sportler hacker will glaubt sich also
meinen dass keine belege aber es gibt
eine option die spannen die konzerne
was einfach schön findet dass sie alle
die gleiche auf der elisabeth spielern
in dem den in dem in dem ruhm und viel
publikum und branchen die auf familien
aber denn wie viele jetzt waren die
regelmäßigen dann wird in das er so
kennenlerne
das finde ich finde zum projekt
schön gefunden und dann die andere
instrument spielen ich finde aber muss
ich eben schön und ich habe immer
dankend einschätzen und bezog dabei
lässt sich das und dann haben sie es
versucht hatte jetzt begeistert so viel
braucht will sie die musiker hat und
dann haben im gegensatz zu mir wenn ich
so blöd das später nicht sicher später
was sie will und dann haben wir die
möglichkeit bot
wenn sie können sich so schnell bewegt
natürlich gekauft und das ihr auch
philips dieser so und damit kann man
sogar das buch kraft klavier für vier
wochen
[Musik]
also ich find's ganz wichtig sich
bewegen wunden machte eingespielt wird
so also dass das wirklich konzentriert
berichtete
[Musik]
was denkst du wie fühlst du dich wenn du
deine tochter sie ist auf der bühne im
schönen kleid
ihre über froh wenn sie fußball live
musikalisch aber doch sportlich macht
manuela keller und andy salat mai auf
dem weg zur tonhalle zürich
[Musik]
in wenigen monaten soll hier der große
auftritt stattfinden
100 kinder und lang lang werden in
diesem ehrwürdigen saal gemeinsam proben
und spielen
aber noch gibt es jede menge
organisatorischer details zu klären
[Musik]
ja richtig
halter geben
die frau steht jetzt kurz erzählen wie
den blauen mit plan ist effizienter so
den clubsport sie zu uns nach eröffnung
wurde die beiden flügel inland sagte
karim etwas machen und wenn wir die
möglichkeit haben das buch hat einfach
die fläche oder ein bisschen zu
verschieben wo reihe schülern und 100 m
also ich denke das kommt uns gab es 27
stufe 8 ist alle frisch und sie hat es
packen und auch innen trag- und abrufbar
sich kurz vor der firma bedienen ist und
sie sind also großzügig sein sie packt
instrumente aus
wenn 100 kleiner pianisten gleichzeitig
loslegen droht ein gigantisches klang
chaos dies zu verhindern ist die aufgabe
von dirigent david bruce shelley
[Gelächter]
aber ich würde es für mich viel besser
da fühlen
und er ist da und dann kann ich ein
bisschen mithelfen das ist sowieso eine
aufgabe diese zu unterstützen sind
skeptischer was ist das objekt digitale
ja auch jetzt sagen wir uns nicht mehr
bieten durch die klavier und tonhalle
und den spieler zum 50
das konnte ich irgendwie komisch und was
soll das
die hin wurde und statisten sind aber
damit befasst und freut sich es wird
also mitzumachen
[Musik]
das ist schneller als man selber gemacht
haben da muss man halt wo die kinder
überhaupt nicht mitkommen lässt sich
erschwerend sein das hinzukriegen mit
zukünftigen verlässlich sind pianisten
spielen sonst wieder wir schauen immer
in die noten fürchten würde sie lassen
[Musik]
ich erwarte mehr möglichkeiten bei den
pädagogischen ich freue mich jetzt genau
wenn wir das jetzt singen und und
pianisten zusammenzubringen wird sicher
ein großes talent
gleichzeitig in den kleinen schritt muss
und dass es gibt spaß und leistung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese maske ist ein bisschen zu klein
[Musik]
spiele klavier seit ich sechs bin also
vier jahren
ich bin stolz auf mich selber
[Musik]
ich finde ich habe gut gewählt also das
theater arbeiten und uns viel leben dass
das geht die früchte
[Musik]
genau wie im tennis zum beispiel man
muss ich trainieren um besser zu werden
und ich will es und darum mache ich es
auch
[Musik]
juni
die darin mio louis rams musikers
informationen
[Musik]
wenn man will jetzt lang lang werden
dann muss man doch sehr diszipliniert
sie ihren tag mit zehn jahren dann schon
jeden tag vier stunden jubeln wenn er
will wandlung werden und später noch mit
13 14 durch 57 stunden und natürlich es
ist schwierig weil sowie alexander
erhard schule deshalb 4 oder 4 uhr und
dann hat er noch bei gehen noch klavier
noch tennis noch schwimmen und zu viele
aktivitäten und es ist schwierig diese
routine mit arbeit zu kriegen
ich weiß nicht wie das kommt jetzt in
zukunft
[Musik]
a
ich habe das im telegraph er spieler wie
so schön ist und ein ganz ganz viele
erste erfolge mit und das rechte ganz
klar
[Musik]
man kann ich nicht zur talk talk wie
wäre es ganz ganz ganz viele kinder aus
spielten spiel soll mit der tt dass ich
weiß wie es aussieht
[Musik]
ja es scheint eine dann der andere dann
der andere in krems nicht
so wird bis riesig rund sowie je nach
zimmer oder lang gelang mit einem bin
wieder voll auftreten und die schlangen
lang zum beispiel ich freue mich gar
nicht so netto fest aber garvey sie ist
dann folgt man sie voll doof ich meinte
stolz ich sehe macht mich ja
[Musik]
musik
alles geschlossen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
teile für sich darstellen
und noch mal einen kleinen oder
teilweise noch einmal machen
[Musik]
das gefällt mir sehr gut hast du noch
eine frage bemerkung merkst du schön
dass jetzt gestaltet ist macht sie
richtig musik aus diesem stück frau wo
gut gehen wir mal bei mozart weiter ich
finde ihn unglaublich musikantisch er
geht richtig mit mit der musik dass das
spürt man das sieht man ihm auch an wenn
er spielt und heute ist mir auch wieder
aufgefallen bin schneller das aufnimmt
anregungen von mir sind wären sofort zu
seinem er interpretiert dann zu seinem
und man spürt richtig jetzt jetzt geht
es richtig los mit der musik
[Musik]
für kinder wird schwierig sein die
gewohnt sind mit den augen auf die noten
zu schauen vielleicht auch noch auf die
kasten und dann sollte man auch noch
nach vorne schauen ich glaube das wird
für viele eine große herausforderung
sein
für jakob denke ich der wird das gut
meistern weil er es gewisse
zusammenspiel schon gewohnt auch von zu
hause aus dass man mit spielt er hat
eigentlich da die möglichkeit noch
wirklich offen zu sein was rundherum
passiert
[Musik]
euro gesichert
vom 22
ok jeder achtung vor
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
noch drei wochen bis zum großen mit
im klavier saal eines zürcher
musikgeschäfts findet die erste
gemeinsame probe statt
[Musik]
du hast dich du bist ja shit
foullong
21 jugendliche
[Musik]
lang lang mit soviel froh dass ich also
wirklich ein luxus mit so vielen
pianistinnen und pianisten zusammen
gespielt und jetzt natürlich werde ich
auch noch muss vorstellen
tötet ihr problem dirigiere und ehrlich
mit der chef immer schön folge das gut
aufpassen bei f ändert sich das tempo
unbedingt zu mir schauen vielleicht
kommen wir durch hier
ok
anpassen
das ist die stelle das ist richtig
[Applaus]
bitter dieser stelle bei klatschen noch
einmal noch einmal probieren wir das zu
fliegen
das ist das läuft nicht so ihr seid
immer noch großartige solisten vielen
dank im orchester geht es darum dass wir
in einander schmelz also dass wir so
spielen wie ein einziger mensch die
ausschließenden china beobachtet da ich
habe auch eine vortrags ist eine
situation hoch entspricht
brand spielt bis ganz anders und muss
sich auf jeden bürger und wo muss ich
über haben in die hand arthur wieder
schlimme sache
die haben noch nicht so viel routine und
dann heißt es wieder und wieder so
ich möchte zuerst probieren separat ihr
seid fasst zusammen
[Musik]
die vorbereitungen sind auf gutem weg
plakate und programmhefte bereits
gedruckt die konzerte mit lang lang
schon längst ausverkauft der große name
garantiert für ein volles haus
doch dann der schock einer entzündung am
arm zwingt lang lang zu einer
entscheidung
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja wir bekamen am zwölften april abend
des 21 uhr die nachricht dass er leider
bis ende juni also über mehrere wochen
ab sein muss und zwar komplett
[Musik]
überhaupt nicht in gedanken sind froh
dass das jetzt auseinanderbricht habe
ich gefunden
das ist sehr schade eigentlich ein
bisschen schwierig noch in halb so
vielen dem namen also es ist schon jetzt
möglich über ein anderer pianist chick
wird erwartet dass er das machtwort
die schweizer sind jetzt zum krieg das
ist ok schon projekt die 14 vorbereitet
die hcp reserviert das muss jetzt keine
stattfinde obwohl ich gegen meine wähler
gestern wenn ihr schon das tram gewerbe
und plötzlich merkt man dass das eben
nicht alles einfach so blau wie ich
meine
[Musik]
am lagerplatz medien awi.de
rechnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich muss sagen der schock dauert bei mir
ungefähr eine stunde und dann geht das
ganz schnell weil man weiß man hat dann
wenig zeit denn auch so viel andere
veranstalterinnen und veranstalter die
ja zeitgleich diese absage bekommen
haben sind auf der suche nach terminen
und diese diesen zeitvorsprung die man
da immer wieder braucht und die
persönlichen kontakte das ist einfach
ein entscheidender vorteil die man
nutzen muss und das tun wir
[Musik]
und da bin ich natürlich glücklich dass
wir haben 27 oktober wiederum ein
freitag um 18 uhr im jahr 2017
und das ist die positive nachricht
dieses projekt in gänze nachholen können
hier im großen saal der tonhalle werden
die kinder und lang lang nicht mehr
spielen können
in der zwischenzeit wurde mit der
totalen renovation des gebäudes begonnen
neue spielstätte ist der frisch
eröffnete konzertsaal im provisorium
tonhalle mark in zürich west
[Musik]
er ist da
das wird jetzt realität ich weiß nicht
wie viele jahre hat
ich bin natürlich als mutter schon sehr
stolz und überhaupt auch als schnee sie
lang lang in zürich eine riesen
überraschung denn bis frühling 2018 hat
er alle konzerte abgesagt doch es gibt
eine einschränkung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine lokale
gleich gibt der pianist der chinesische
pianist lang lang diesem prozess den
feinschliff
sie haben also ein blick in einen
workshop der vor vielen monaten begonnen
hat und der heute den krönenden
abschluss findet wir begrüßen ihn
welcome to the pianist lang lang
danke very happy to be here
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als er friedlich
mit
[Musik]
burg nicht durch
na bitte
doch plakate finden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
u
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
volk ruhig
doch nicht nur um musik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
sprossen
sehr gut
und er so dass alba voll
nein man kann nicht darstellen solche
verfahren kann ich eigentlich bekannt
das sind dann die lange aber
die kursk hat also was gerade besser
machen könnte
nicht nur gespielt hat wirklich ist ein
ganz glücklicher schlusspunkt von der
langen arbeit
schön sind seine spieler und das ist
sehr schön
die energie die stimme ich finde das ist
ja ich habe es 14 ist großartig da war
die konzentration war ein start
unmöglich auf einen moment auf das
konzert bleibe auf dem moment die
klingen der sache war in einer probe
zahlreichen das ist jemand schrieb im
stabhochsprung verjagte starb oder der
magischen welt geworden
also wie er gesagt hat merkel gewandt
also wenn man eine echte musiker
karriere machen will muss man sich
aufregen
[Musik]
usa
august die luft
als ihm ein talent
[Musik]